I asked this at this if he thought Trump
should attend the next debate yeah I
mean look I think he owes it to the to
the public to debate I think the the
idea that he's entitled to be nominated
is absurd I think that there's a lot of
questions that he needs to answer uh
both about how he would win the election
uh but also about some of the decisions
that he made as president you pointed
out the fauci and then there are others
so I think he should do it he probably
won't do it uh and that's fine I'm going
to be there regardless I do think you're
going to see a smaller stage because I
think some of those folks aren't going
to qualify for this next round and look
my thing is is you know it's far be it
for me to tell anyone who to run or not
run but uh you either have a path or you
don't and if you don't have a path then
we should focus on the candidates you
know that have a that have a conceivable
shot at this um I will say though being
on that stage I think one of the reasons
why you know I wasn't necessarily the
target as much as people thought is I
have a record of success I've done the
things that people are talking about
that we need to do for this country
country in Florida across the board and
so I'm armed with the ability to say
that I've done it and also to point out
you know whatever shortcomings would be
from somebody that's lobbing a grenade
my way so I'm prepared to do however it
shakes out but if it's just me and I get
something I want to look into the camera
and tell people my vision of how to
reverse this country's decline beat
Biden and get us on a better path and
and I think we all know we need to do
that I'm the one guy that has a record
of showing how it can be done with how
we've transformed Florida you guys know
how I always say the thing about how
when you're listening to someone tell
the truth it's just kind of easy to
listen to like you can sit back you can
breathe you can relax it's obvious and
and all of that was true I want to make
two points on this uh you know this line
about how he would win meaning Trump has
to explain how he would win this is a
major major point if Trump believes and
he does he keeps repeatedly saying it
that the last election was stolen well
you might say I'm the guy who's going to
drain the swamp and I'm the guy who they
stole the election from and you can say
all of that stuff you can rile up that
base and all of that and you can
convince everyone the election was
stolen and I I don't even have to offer
an opinion on that but if that is your
argument then the second piece of your
argument has to be and here's how I will
stop them from doing it again but as far
as I know Trump has done literally
nothing on that so if you if you
absolutely love Trump and again the
country was better under him if he is
the nominee I'm gonna vote for him I
don't think he's profoundly evil I don't
have TDS I've basically broken bread
with the guy all of that stuff that you
know but if he can't lay out oh that
they stole it for me last time I'm just
gonna do it all over again the exact
same way if he can't explain how that
won't happen again that's a bit of a
flaw so you really need to think about
that then I want to address one other
thing about debating specifically
because DeSantis is saying yeah he
should debate he probably won't you know
at the uh at the first debate in
Milwaukee when we did our post game show
with Glenn Greenwald and Michael malice
and Jordan Peterson Jordan said
something that I think really hit the
nail on the head he said in a healthy
democracy Donald Trump and Joe Biden
would both be debating now I see a lot
of trump people right now going well
look at these National polls and he's up
by 50 points and he can only lose
there's no win in it for him so he
shouldn't have to now that at a purely
tactical strategic level if you only
think that all of this is a game and
it's only about like winning in the most
sort of uh narrow sense of the word then
I suppose Trump should not to be right
because I guess yes he could get on that
debate stage and DeSantis would go right
at him and Nikki would probably go right
Adam and Pence might go right out of
vivec won't because he's he's sort of
his pet at the moment but he might take
some fire but the point is in a truly
healthy democracy as Jordan said we
would be debating ideas in a better way
right Trump wouldn't be afraid of
Defending his record saying here are the
few mistakes that I made you know he
still won't admit he really made made
any mistakes around covid and Joe Biden
would be willing to debate say RFK Jr or
someone else who might be on the
Democrat side of things foreign